us sanktionen sollen die türkei stoppen
die kämpfe im norden syriens gehen
trotzdem weiter werden sogar heftiger
debakel pkw maut die opposition wirft
verkehrsminister schwere fehler vor und
will einen untersuchungsausschuss
einsetzen
norwegen als ehrengast zur eröffnung der
frankfurter buchmesse reist das
kronprinzenpaar im literatur zu kann
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem dienstag an meiner seite ist für
den sportler wirklich kein wunder von
mir fast 200.000 menschen sind
mittlerweile auf der flucht vor den
türkischen angriffen in nordsyrien
darunter fast 70.000 kinder wie viele
tote und verletzte es gibt wissen wir
nicht us-präsident trump der mit dem
abzug seiner truppen diese türkische
offensive erst ermöglichte versucht
jetzt offenbar den schaden zu begrenzen
er fordert einen sofortigen
waffenstillstand und erhöht den druck
auf ankara mit sanktionen strafzöllen
etwa auf stahl und der drohung ein
handelsabkommen auf eis zu legen
vizepräsident pence soll baldmöglichst
zu verhandlungen in die türkei reisen
die gefechte im türkisch syrischen
grenzgebiet gehen währenddessen weiter
gequalmt berichtet in nordsyrien wird
weiter auf breiter front gekämpft
türkische truppen und ihrer verbündeten
stehen vor der stadt man beach westlich
des euphrat dort waren gestern soldaten
der us-armee unterstützt von russischen
militärs eingetroffen
das außenministerium in moskau erklärte
heute
man wolle eine konfrontation vermeiden
und stehe in engem kontakt mit ankara
und damaskus
es werde versucht eine einigung über die
jeweiligen kontrollzonen zu erreichen
us-präsident trump forderte die türkei
in einem tweet auf die offensive sofort
zu stoppen
die us-regierung verhängte sanktionen
gegen mehrere türkische minister sowie
strafzölle auf stahlimporte der
präsident hat mich und
sicherheitsberater o'brien beauftragt so
rasch wie möglich in die türkei zu
reisen um in verhandlungen ein schnelles
ende des blutvergießens zu erreichen
die märkte reagierten kaum auf die
angekündigten sanktionen die türkische
währung blieb weitgehend stabil
volkswagen kündigte an die entscheidung
zum bau eines neuen werks in der türkei
auf einen späteren zeitpunkt zu vertagen
präsident erdogan bekräftigte bei einem
besuch in aserbaidschan
man werde die offensive fortsetzen 1000
quadratkilometer seien schon von
terroristen gesäubert
so gott will werden wir von mann bridge
bis zur irakischen grenze sichere
bedingungen für die freiwillige rückkehr
von ein bis zwei millionen syrischen
flüchtlingen schaffen nach angaben der
vereinten nationen sind bereits 150.000
menschen entlang der grenze auf der
flucht morgen will sich in new york der
un sicherheitsrat erneut mit der
türkischen militär offensive befassen
wenn man sie wissen in washington erst
sie trumps seine truppen aus nordsyrien
ab und macht damit den weg frei für die
türkische offensive jetzt will er mit
sanktionen ankara stoppen
wie ist diese außenpolitik zu erklären
er will damit zumindest signalisieren
dass er was unternimmt gegen erdogans
truppen aber kritiker sagen ganz klar
das ist reine symbolpolitik der in
vizepräsident pence reist eigentlich aus
einer position der schwäche heraus nach
ankara soll da etwas stoppen was
eigentlich der amerikanische präsident
selber vor zehn tagen in einem telefonat
mit dem türkischen präsidenten erdogan
naja zumindest mal nicht dagegengehalten
hat er hat es damit im grunde möglich
gemacht und zum zweiten reist er mit
einem sehr kleinen hebel wobei der
größtmögliche hebel doch da wäre der
kleine hebel sanktionen die brauchen
tage vielleicht sogar wochen bis die
wirkung entfalten zeit genug um fakten
am boden zu schaffen während der größere
hebel einfach zu sagen da bleiben die
us-truppen wer weiter vorgeht der
richtet sich gegen amerikanische
interessen dieser größere hebel bleibt
liegen
insofern der vorwurf reine symbolpolitik
russland versucht die neuen verhältnisse
in nordsyrien für sich zu nutzen welche
rolle später sind den usa eine große
weil auch republikanische senatoren im
kongress ganz klar sagen hier ist etwas
verloren gegangen für das man jahrelang
gekämpft hat man hat jetzt freie bahn
dem assad-regime russland und vor allen
dingen iran gegeben die große sorge dass
iran in der lage ist dadurch einen
zugang zum mittelmeer
zu bekommen über eben syrien über das
assad-regime und damit auch israel zu
bedrohen
also hier gibt es tiefe sorgen und das
könnte den präsidenten auch im eigenen
lager bei den republikanern auf den fuß
fallen einschätzung aus washington von
elmar theveßen vielen dank die usa
russland die türkei die kurden das
assad-regime viele mission mit im
syrienkonflikt wer im krisengebiet genau
mit wem gegen wen kämpft das haben wir
für sie noch einmal aufbereitet und
heute.de nach deutschland zur
gescheiterten pkw maut die wird für den
verkehrsminister immer unangenehmer noch
im januar hatte andreas scheuer
verkündet somit ist fix die pkw maut
kommt zum oktober 2020 so ist es
vertraglich vereinbart doch sie bekommt
bekanntlich nicht europas höchstes
gericht stoppte die maus stattdessen
kommt nun ein untersuchungsausschuss auf
scheuer zu hauptvorwurf er habe
millionenschwere verträge unterschrieben
bevor das projekt rechtlich abgesichert
war
patricia wiedemeier die pkw-maut sie
waren das prestige-projekt der csu
festgehalten im koalitionsvertrag 2013
zwei csu verkehrsminister dobrindt und
scheuer kämpften für ihre einführung und
setzen sie auch durch ende 2018 vergab
scheuer die aufträge ein halbes jahr
später jedoch kippte der europäische
gerichtshof die maut erklärte sie für
europarechtswidrig doch der minister
gibt sich auch danach betont lässig und
keiner schuld bewusst vor allem in
seinen selbst produzierten videos wir
stehen bei allen fragen zur pkw maut für
maximal mögliche transparenz
doch jetzt könnte es eng werden für
andreas scheuer er hat milliardenschwere
verträge zur kontrolle der maut
besiegelt ohne das gerichtsurteil
abzuwarten den firmen damit hohe
entschädigungszahlungen gesichert zudem
gab es einige treffen mit den betreibern
die nicht dokumentiert wurden ein
untersuchungsausschuss soll jetzt für
klarheit sorgen
also wir wissen
relativ sicher dass herr scheuer an sehr
vielen stellen trickst und täuscht wir
haben bis heute minister vorlagen nicht
bekommen er hat vor allen dingen das ist
sicherlich das schwerwiegendste mehrere
hundert millionen wenn nicht sogar eine
milliarde euro an steuergeldern
verschwendet nach unserer auffassung ist
andreas scheuer nicht mehr haltbar
vorbehaltlos hinter scheider steht
derzeit nur noch die eigene fraktion der
stuhl von herrn steuer der wackelt
natürlich nicht der stuhl des
verkehrsministers wackeln nicht da es ja
einen klaren auftrag des gesetzgebers
gegeben habe und überhaupt so scheuer er
habe nichts zu verbergen
ich hab den antragsentwurf zum
untersuchungsausschuss gesehen ich habe
alle punkte durchgegangen und bin
draufgekommen dass wir eigentlich zu
allen gegenständen schon auskunft
gegeben haben aber dann geben wir heute
wieder auskunft
es ist nicht viel übrig geblieben vom
prestige projekt der csu für sie geht es
jetzt vor allem um schadensbegrenzung
nach dem terroranschlag in halle mit
zwei toten deutliche worte heute von den
deutschen sicherheitsbehörden
rechtsextremismus sei zunehmend eine
gefahr für die demokratie sagte der chef
des bundeskriminalamts münch die
situation sei ernst
derzeit würden im rechten spektrum 43
personen als gefährder eingestuft das
heißt man traut ihnen schwere
gewalttaten zu die tatsächliche zahl so
münch könnte aber höher liegen die
strompreise in deutschland ohnehin schon
vergleichsweise hoch werden im kommenden
jahr nochmals steigen laut den
netzbetreibern wird die sogenannte eeg
umlage erhöht um 5,5 prozent auf dann
6,7 6 cent pro kilowattstunde beispiel
einen vier-personen-haushalt mit einem
durchschnitts stromverbrauch muss etwa
18 euro pro jahr mehr bezahlen
mit der umlage wird der ausbau von
erneuerbaren energien in deutschland
gefördert
in katalonien brodelt die volksseele die
hohen haftstrafen für die anführer der
unabhängigkeitsbewegung haben viele
menschen empört und auf die straßen
getrieben
mehrere hundert stürmten am späten abend
gewaltsam den flughafen von barcelona es
gab viele verletzte und für heute abend
wird ähnlich
das befürchtet thomas weide berichtet
die ruhe die heute in barcelona herrscht
ist angespannt ungewöhnlich viele
sicherheitskräfte zeigen präsenz wie
hier am bahnhof schon wer hinein will
muss seinen fahrschein vorzeigen
also ich kann verstehen dass menschen
auf der straße demonstrieren aber man
sollte es nicht so machen dass der ganze
verkehr zusammenbricht
gestern abend versuchten demonstranten
den flughafen lahm zu legen sie warfen
objekte und zerschlugen fensterscheiben
polizisten setzten schlagstöcke ein
170 menschen wurden verletzt reisende
irrten umher
reihenweise wurden flüge gestrichen auch
heute wir sitzen seit gestern abend hier
fest wir haben die nacht hier verbracht
wir warten auf den nächsten flug heute
um 20 uhr
der schlagabtausch um das urteil gegen
katalanische politiker wegen aufruhr
gingen heute weiter beweisen empört
dieses politische urteil zurück dass
gegen demokratische und friedliche
menschen verhängt wurde
richter sollen keine politischen
probleme lösen sie wenden das recht an
dunkle mäntel für heute abend werden die
nächsten proteste in barcelona erwartet
auf der griechischen insel samos ist ein
flüchtlingslager nach einem großbrand
evakuiert worden
das feuer war gestern abend auf einem
streit zwischen syrien und afghanen
ausgebrochen
es kam zu schlägereien und krawallen
mehrere menschen wurden verletzt
das lager ist mit mehr als 4000
bewohnern völlig überfüllt dort gibt es
eigentlich nur platz für rund 600
menschen
wenn kinder schlecht essen leben sie
schlecht sagt die leiterin des
kinderhilfswerks unicef das heute seinen
neuen bericht vorgestellt hat demnach
sind weltweit 149 millionen kinder unter
fünf jahren wegen mangelernährung
unterentwickelt also zu klein für ihr
alter weitere 50 millionen haben
schlicht nicht genug zu essen
aber auch das gehört zur fehl ernährung
40 millionen kinder unter fünf sind
übergewichtig oder fettleibig
wir sehen dass millionen von
dann zu viel von dem essen was sie nicht
brauchen und zu wenig von dem was sie
brauchen zum beispiel sehen wir dass
kleinkinder häufig nicht produkte wie
tierische produkte bekommen als auch
obst oder gemüse und mit zunehmendem
alter wird es nicht besser stichwort
fastfood seit dem jahr 2000 hat sich die
zahl der übergewichtigen zwischen 5 und
19 fast verdoppelt unicef fordert mehr
aufklärung über gesunde ernährung und
jetzt zur frage was jugendliche derzeit
denken und meinen da gibt es jetzt eine
neue studie für deutschland und die
zeichnet ungefähr dieses bild oft
engagiert politisch interessiert auf den
straßen bei fridays for future 71
prozent der 12 bis 25 jährigen sagen die
zerstörung der umwelt mache ihnen angst
platz eins in der studie noch vor
terroranschlägen aber die befragung
zeigt auch sehr viele sind zugänglich
für populistische parolen sandra saison
auch sie sind teil dieser generation
rund ein drittel der jugendlichen
übernehmen leicht populistische
positionen zu glauben 33 prozent von
ihnen dass die regierung der bevölkerung
die wahrheit verschweigt 20 prozent
zumindest teilweise auf jeden fall
klappt es gehört immer zur politik das
man muss vielleicht alles weiß also das
sollte nicht so sein aber das glaube ich
in den meisten fällen so ich denke wenn
die bürger immer die wahrheit wissen
dass es in deutschland sehr vielen
unruhen kommen würde
ergebnisse der aktuellen shell studie
mit dem titel eine generation meldet
sich zu wort
überraschend für die forscher die
empfänglichkeit für politischen
populismus wächst wenn sie den jungen
leuten nicht gut gehen wenn sie mit der
bildung nicht gut zurecht kommen vor
allem auch in ihre wirtschaftliche lage
schlecht ist wenn sie glauben dass es
ihnen nicht gut gehen wird
dann werden sie politisch kritisch dann
fangen sie an zu suchen nach einfachen
antworten und dann sind auch
populistische und nationalistische und
autoritäre positionen für sie durchaus
interessant ein anderes drittel der
jugendlichen setzt auf verstärktes
politisches engagement ist gut gebildet
beides verfügte engagiere ich mich ich
habe selber weiß dafür gemacht noch also
ich wehre mich vegetarisch und ich finde
es ist wichtig sich zu wort zu melden
und zu sagen was einem wichtig ist eine
mehrheit findet sich wenn es um die
eigene perspektive geht fast 60 prozent
schauen ihr zuversichtlich in die eigene
zukunft
gesundheitsministerin im kabinett
schmedt bundestags-vizepräsidentin
vorsitzende des mieterbunds nur drei von
vielen ämtern die anke fuchs innehatte
jetzt ist die spd politikerin mit 82
jahren gestorben
als juristin stritt sie für frauenrechte
galt als volksnah und genoss über
parteigrenzen hinweg große anerkennung
hoher besuch heute zum auftakt der
frankfurter buchmesse zum einen konnte
man die frisch gekürte polnische
literatur nobelpreisträgerin olga
tokarczuk erleben
zum anderen gab sich das kronprinzenpaar
aus norwegen die ehre
peter 30
großer andrang beim königlichen besuch
mette marit und kronprinz haakon kommen
pünktlich an mit dem literatur zug zur
eröffnung der buchmesse unterwegs
erklärte die prinzessin ihre faszination
für bücher
sie tragen zum verständnis der anderen
bei
das ist für mich die schönheit der
literatur wir können uns selbst dadurch
besser verstehen lernen und auch die
anderen literatur ist aber auch wichtig
weil sie uns etwas gemeinsames schenkt
etwas das uns vereint norwegen das
gastland der buchmesse
hier ist das wort so frei wie in keinem
anderen staat der erde
diese freiheit ist nicht
selbstverständlich das beobachtet auch
die literaturnobelpreisträgerin olga
tokarczuk in ihrer heimat in polen
in polen gibt es keine offizielle
literarische zensur aber ich stelle fest
dass gerade eine art selbstzensur
auftaucht dh dass die schriftsteller
gewissermaßen angst davor haben zu
schreiben was sie wirklich denken und
empfinden weil sie sich vor den
möglichen politischen konsequenzen
fürchten
wir sehen es überall auf der welt wie
sich sprachräume wie sich nationen
abschließen wie sich indien abschottet
was in china passiert das thema um
hongkong
es gibt aber auch gute nachrichten aus
der welt der bücher
die verkaufszahlen steigen wieder nicht
nur beim e-book sondern auch beim guten
alten gedruckten wort der fußball bringt
heute keine freude norbert der ganz neu
entgleisungen bei em qualifikation zu
jahr wieder ein typischer militärische
salut bei einem spiel diesmal in paris
und in sofia beim spiel bulgarien gegen
england hitlergruß und rassistische
beleidigungen aus dem heimischen
publikum
die uefa hat jetzt gegen dem wiederholt
auffällig gewordenen bulgarischen
verband ein disziplinarverfahren
eingeleitet
mit sechs toren gaben englands fußballer
ihre antwort auf dem platz die antwort
auf affenlaute die den schwarzen
spielern entgegen gerufen wurden und die
hitler größe zweimal wurde das spiel
unterbrochen und der halbzeit beriet das
englische team ob es überhaupt noch
einmal auflaufen solle alle wollten
weitermachen und es denen zeigen und
darauf bin ich stolz ich habe mit frau
dr
natürlich kann man uns vorwerfen nicht
weit genug gegangen zu sein aber ich
denke schon dass wir ein ausrufezeichen
gesetzt haben
es war so gut wie unmöglich es unter
diesen umständen allen recht zu machen
doch wenn sich das alles als erwiesen
herausstellt müssen wir uns schäden und
uns entschuldigen
die vorfälle in sofia beschäftigten am
mittag sogar das britische parlament und
in bulgarien musste der vorsitzende des
fußballverbands inzwischen seinen posten
räumen
ja und dann noch die erneute politische
provokation türkische nationalspieler
bei der em quali begegnung in frankreich
wie schon beim gruppenspiel gegen
albanien demonstrativer militärischer
salut dem sich aber der torschütze zum 1
1 endstand verweigerte kaan ayhan von
fortuna düsseldorf traf zum ausgleich
machte diesmal aber nicht mit beim
strittigen torjubel mit mary dem iran
von juventus turin nummer drei kam es
daraufhin zu einem kurzen disput die zur
schau gestellte solidarität mit den
soldaten der türkei offensive in
nordsyrien ist team kalkül und wird in
der heimat mit stolz verfolgt dieser
militär groß bringt keine negative
haltung zum ausdruck wir wollen auch
lieber dass unsere soldaten im land
bleiben
es geschieht alle sind gutem glauben um
unsere soldaten zu unterstützen die uefa
verbietet ausdrücklich politische
äußerungen in stadien
tja leider wird die sportliches im sport
heute ein wenig sonne gibt es morgen
noch im süden ansonsten wird es grau und
regnerisch details hat gleich katze
honnefer im heute journal um viertel vor
zehn begrüßt sie christian sieh was wir
danken für ihren presse wünschen ihnen
noch einen schönen abend unsere morgen
wieder da wenn sie morgen auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren über
genua gab es unwetter und die linken
zusammen mit diesem tief hier
die brachten mehrere hundert liter regen
pro quadratmeter
das tief sebastian bei uns brachte
deutlich weniger regen und heute gab es
nicht nur etwas regen sondern auch viel
nebel
zumindest hier im donautal das dauerte
in den späten nachmittag bis sich die
nebelfelder dann alle auflösten
gleichzeitig zog die kaltfront von tief
sebastian heran und sie zieht jetzt
weiter in richtung osten in der nacht
liegt sie dann zwischen der nordseeküste
und dem alpenrand selten bildet sich mal
etwas nebel
es kann auch einzelne gewitter dabei
sein die temperaturen sinken auf 13 grad
in nordfriesland und bis 5 grad am
alpenrand und morgen wird es zumindest
in schleswig holstein und dem
mecklenburg-vorpommern kaum wärmer mit
14 grad
dort regnet es nämlich vor allen dingen
am vormittag noch sehr ergiebig weiter
und erst am nachmittag zieht der regen
hier über die ostsee ab dann gibt es
einen freundlichen streifen vom
jadebusen bis zum harz und von westen
kommt schon der nächste regen heran wer
trifft dann auch rheinland pfalz und das
saarland südlich der donau wird es
deutliche sonnig bei temperaturen von
bis zu 20 grad wechselhaft und mild geht
es in den nächsten tagen weiter schönen
abend noch